at churches around indonesia military
and police are screening worshipers
before they enter
good friday is one of the most important
days in the christian calendar
this holy week there's heightened
security with personnel at the gates and
armoured vehicles
standing by
i feel that indonesians live peacefully
side by side our diversity is beautiful
but there are people who want to disturb
the security
on sunday in the eastern port city of
makassar a married couple detonated a
bomb
near a cathedral injuring 20 people
it is not shocking anymore every time
there is a christmas celebration
easter celebration or
pre-ramadan preparation period
sadly to say there are open attack
against
christian churches the bombers died in
the attack
since then police have arrested
suspected associates of the couple
who were linked to an isil-affiliated
network
in 2018 a family of six detonated
explosives at several churches in the
city of surabaya
killing more than a dozen christians
security forces have cracked down on
these violent networks in recent years
and arrested a number of key individuals
while attacks are less frequent than
they were in the early 2000s
experts say religious intolerance is
still a security concern
de-radicalization experts say combating
hatred against minorities
is part of their work
we have to give them a new understanding
of religion tell them to let go of their
contradictory understanding
and the beliefs which they use to
justify their wrong actions
security experts say the landscape has
changed
and there are new challenges the
recruitment is very fast
and using uh social media is one of its
tools you know so
rather than purely collective accent no
it's a connective accent
experts say the government should do
more to protect minorities
all citizens are equal whether you are
sunni muslim ahmadiyya muslims see are
muslim christians
buddhists local believers or whatever
so the government needs to make sure
that everyone is treated equally
in indonesia indonesia's president
insists people should continue their
religious activities without fear
but for some that is a difficult
prospect jessica washington al jazeera
jakarta